[Musique]
il faut dire que
la plupart des gens de les agents de la
rivière ils passent par là trois pour
aller sur sur la côte quoi
le radier c'est un radis fusible en
moyenne en deux fois deux fois emporté
tous les ans lors du logo de cyclones ou
de grosses crues le département a pris
le parti de refaire de reconstruire à
chaque fois les radiers c'est moins
onéreux et notre service fait le maximum
pour rétablir la circulation dans le
minimum de temps à partir du moment où
on a des couilles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le fondre la peine qui dessert
l'antre-2 qui a été construit et qui
permet le passage de goût véhicules
lourds sur la commune de l'entré deux
sachant que le pont métallique est
limitée à 20 tonnes un camion qui a tapé
dans une poutre et puis qui a fait
fondre répond au lieu de reconstruire
les ouvrages on l'a
il a été décidé de refaire le noyage sur
le bras de la plaine plus haut et où on
a pu
mur et lui enlever la limitation de
tonnage pour monter champions
[Musique]